so i stopped abruptly 12 minutes into
the last video because 12 minutes was
too long i needed a break but where we
left off we were in the home stretch we
were evaluating the third surface
integral and we were setting it up as a
double integral with respect to
r and theta and we just had to set up
the bounds and we know that r takes on
values between zero and one and theta
takes on values between zero and two pi
so r we're gonna we're gonna integrate
with respect to r first r takes on
values between zero and one and theta
takes on values between 0 and 2 pi
0 and 2 pi and so now we are ready to
integrate so let's do the first part
let's do this inside part right over
here and i'm just going to rewrite the
outside part so this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to we have our
square root of 2
square root of 2 times the integral from
0 to 2 pi
of
and we have d theta right over here
d theta right over here so that's the
outside this inside part right over here
we can rewrite it as if we distribute
the r we it's r
minus r squared
r minus r squared cosine of theta now
we're going to integrate with respect to
r so when we integrate with respect to r
cosine of theta is just a constant so if
you integrate this with respect to r
you get and i'll do it in that i'll do
that pink color
if you integrate with respect to r the
anti-derivative of r is r squared over
two
so it's r squared over two and the
anti-derivative of r squared is r cubed
over three
minus
r cubed over three
cosine theta this is just a constant r
cubed over 3 cosine theta and we're
going to evaluate that from 0 to 1
0 to 1. so when you would evaluate it at
1 you get 1 half minus one-third cosine
theta so you get one-half i'll just do
it right over here one-half minus
one-third
cosine
theta and then minus both of these
evaluated at zero well that's just going
to be those are just going to be 0 0
squared minus 0 squared times whatever
it's all going to be 0. so this business
right over here just evaluates to one
half minus 1 3 cosine of theta and so we
get the integral this is all going to be
equal now to the square root of 2 times
the integral from theta 0 to 2 pi
of
one-half minus 1 3
cosine of theta
d theta and this is equal to square root
of two times the antiderivative of one
half is one half
one half theta and the antiderivative of
cosine theta is sine theta so minus one
third
sine theta and we're evaluating it from
0 to 2 pi when you evaluate these at 2
pi you have let me just write it all out
it's a home stretch i don't want to make
a careless mistake we have square root
of 2
times let's evaluate it at two pi one
half times two pi is pi minus one third
times sine of two pi well that's just
going to be zero and when you evaluate
it at zero zero times
zero or one half times zero is zero sine
of zero zero so that all comes out to
zero so all of this business simplifies
to pi
and we are done we have evaluated
surface three it is square root of two
or the third surface integral or the
surface integral over surface three it
is square root of two pi
and we are done
so this part right over here this part
right over here is square root of square
root 2 or root 2
times pi so this entire surface integral
that we started like 80 videos ago
evaluates to the orange part values to
zero the blue part three pi over two and
then the magenta part is square root of
two pi so we're left with three pi over
two plus square to two pi is the value
of our original surface integral